what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up with darth vader but
there were a few questions in relation
to star wars comics that you guys had um
and some requests as well which again
you know it's really up to you guys i
mean i think the star wars comics are
cool we can cover them right you guys
really seem to enjoy darth vader the
number one question you guys had largely
because a lot of you are probably fans
of the mandalorian tv show is you wanted
to know if there's a comic book series
that covers the mandalorian wars
themselves for example like the
mandalorian wars part one or part two or
part three no there really isn't uh
there's what's called knight to the old
republic and then there's a five-issue
mini-series called kotor war which
basically that five issue mini-series
focuses on the mandalorian wars but the
knights of the old republic storyline is
think of it akin to uh what was going on
with like anakin skywalker in episodes
one two and three that like the clone
wars were going on and like you saw some
stuff happening but the story was mostly
about anakin that's basically how it is
in knights of the old republic the
mandalorian wars are going on but it's
less about the wars themselves and more
about the main character of the story
the other question you guys had is how
these comics work and basically marvel
takes it in phases this is technically
phase two we actually kind of skipped
ahead that basically what we're doing
now with darth vader takes place after
the events of empire strikes back but
before the events of return of the jedi
phase one was basically everything after
a new hope so episode four and then
we'll probably do the obi-wan series
once we get closer to the show uh but
continuing on here because darth vader
had basically ignored the request of the
emperor to return and basically brief
the emperor on what had gone on in the
efforts of empire strikes back to turn
luke skywalker to the dark side that
darth vader had in turn gone on his own
mission to basically figure out what had
happened with the death of padme to find
out if what the emperor had told him if
there was any real truth to it um of
course he ended up finding out the truth
that basically he was not the reason
padme died that the emperor had lied and
so once he returned here the emperor
immediately starts attacking him of
course now one of the things to know is
this kind of a bit of training is sort
of what's happening here but the emperor
of course uses forced lightning kind of
a signature weapon at this point in time
or his signature power at this point in
time now of course darth vader asked the
question why are you attacking me and
that's when you basically end up getting
the grand vizier of the emperor who
steps in right masamida and basically
says like here's what's going on that
the reality here is that it wasn't
necessarily that vader had gone on his
own mission to find out what had
happened with the death of uh of padme
amidala and all that kind of stuff the
emperor knew it was inevitable before
vader found out the truth that and that
eventually he would the hope of the
emperor here and it proved to be a
successful campaign as with most of the
stuff that he's done his hope was to
turn anakin to the dark side re-christen
him as lord vader so by the time he
learned the truth it wouldn't matter
he'd be so far down the dark side there
wouldn't really be any way to redeem him
more so than that as things are told
here that he basically that it really
kind of goes back to empire strikes back
that vader basically found luke
skywalker he was tasked with bringing
him to the dark side and he didn't do it
not only that he let him escape that in
reality when luke skywalker fell down
the shaft right and was literally
hanging at the bottom of the citadel in
cloud city that what vader should have
done was gone after him right and then
snatched him up and even if vader
couldn't turn to the dark side amber
palpatine could beyond that he left on
his own personal mission which was
everything we covered in the last story
and so it's really kind of listed that
basically being at best it's total
failure at worst it's absolute treason
and when the question of the emperor is
what do we do with traitors the response
of masumida is we kill them and that's
when the emperor seeks his guards on
vader now the reality here is the
emperor does not actually expect his
guards to kill vader they're wildly
capable they're like the emperor's
personal guard they're incredibly
capable but honestly the emperor never
expected that to happen and in fact one
of the things that happens of course
vader dons his lightsaber uses his uses
the force and the emperor strips his
lightsaber away and is like no and of
course what's really cool here is even
without his lightsaber vader's still a
force to be reckoned with and that's one
of the things that people have a
tendency to sort of forget when it comes
to darth vader that in terms of like
mobility and maneuverability and being
able to fight in the same capacity that
he did when he was anakin having all
those different uh force stances and so
on and so forth that he's not as capable
as he used to be but he's still powerful
as hell
and so you'd have to be some kind of
fool to run up on darth vader and
believe because he's basically a guy in
a metal suit that he's not as powerful
as he was when he was anakin and it'd be
easy to walk all over it right only a
fool would do that and so literally what
happens here is once vader uses the
force on masamita and the the imperial
guards and so on and so forth that in
turn uh basically the emperor uses the
force on him and that's what he says is
like how does it feel to be so weak
right to feel such pain to no such fear
because in essence the emperor is giving
vader a taste of what he's given to
everybody else and in the end well the
responsive vader is like you lied to me
right you lied to me about how it was
that padme amidala died the response of
of the emperor isn't like so what who
cares it doesn't matter his response is
really interesting here he says you
proved my point it was your fear of
losing padme that brought you to my side
i turned your weakness into strength but
now your weakness returns and threatens
everything you've gained so let me teach
you fear again and bring you back to
power that from palpatine's perspective
that fear is really the root of power
right that fear can be manipulated it
can be controlled and if you can turn a
person to the dark side and you can turn
them into your apprentice you can in
turn gain power right like literally
fear leads to power is a philosophy of
the sith and so what ends up happening
here really palpatine in the moment says
like forget everything right he
literally just starts using the force
and breaking vader's body apart to the
point where it's really like his arms
legs essentially all his machine
components are basically eradicated not
in the sense that it'll kill him but it
reduces him down to his most base form
and he says you must find yourself again
old friend you must relearn the primacy
of power above all else or you must die
and so what he does in one of the
coolest moments is he takes him back to
mustafar exactly where uh where emperor
palpatine found him after his fight with
uh obi-wan kenobi and losing his legs
and everything and becoming a crispy
critter and ultimately like drops him
off and it's just like you will not use
the force right you you can there's your
lightsaber right use it if you feel like
you need to but you cannot draw on the
force you have to go strictly by you
just your your guts and your your
fortitude and your strength nothing more
than that if you use the force i will
know and this whole exercise will come
to an end i will destroy you and i will
go find luke skywalker myself and i will
make him my apprentice now this is a
really really cool concept because i
wouldn't i would not call myself an
expert on the expanded universe in star
wars by any standard of measurement but
what i would say is that one of my
favorite aspects of the expanded
universe was knights of the old republic
too when it came to uh what is it crea
who turned out to be a sith lord darth
treya but one of the things that she
talked about is how feeble both sith
lords and jedi work that if you take
away the force and you take away the
lightsaber what are they right they're
just people fumbling around in the dark
they don't know how to use blasters or
anything like that they are wildly
incapable and her belief system her view
of anybody out there looking to become
powerful in the force was to first
become the most peak version of
themselves they could without the force
to take their weaknesses and make them
strengths so they wouldn't have to rely
on the force in order to become powerful
the force would complement them it
wouldn't become a crutch and that's how
she saw a lot of sith and jedi that they
basically used the force as a crutch in
order to achieve their goals and so in
essence that's the lesson that palpatine
is teaching vader here that the force
that he's been using it as a crutch in a
lot of ways and that he has to basically
regain his roots in terms of
understanding just how powerful he is
and so as a result of this vader
basically makes his way to the uh to the
ruins of the techno union installation
which you guys probably remember from
episode 3 which had a lot of machine
components quite literally going there
to rebuild himself but in the midst of
it all and to test him even further that
emperor palpatine basically ends up ends
up sending ochi of uh best dude now you
guys probably recall this guy if from
nothing else than rise of skywalker that
those movies that exist that people made
and now we're here uh that that ochi was
basically the guy who held on to uh had
a wayfinder that they were hunting for
so it was like lando and it was rey and
it was finn and they were like racing
along the sand to try to find it you
guys would know that scene if you saw it
but like they were going to find him
right so basically at that point he was
dead but at this point in time he is a
set assassin now i'm not very well
versed in this guy's whole history so
honestly i'll defer to you all as star
wars fans down in the comments section
uh to really just provide the
information there for this guy which of
course you know you'll teach me
and you'll teach everybody else contrary
to what you might believe i don't know
everything about everything ever there
are things that i don't necessarily know
and this is one of those so
there's actually a lot that i don't know
but the cool thing about this is that
vader kind of draws on his own
experiences in doing this right and i
don't i don't really even know if it's
necessarily greg greg pack kind of
giving us this illustration of like
darth vader getting back to his roots or
anything like that but it's really just
kind of creating a bit of nostalgia for
us as the reader that the last time
vader was here he was killing everybody
right he was eradicating what was left
of the separatist group basically any
opposition that existed that could stand
in the way of what was going on with
emperor palpatine remember that was the
plan right that was the that was
literally the entire third act of
episode three is it was basically uh
palpatine finally making his move as the
emperor wiping out the separatists
getting rid of the jedi like he'd
already taken over the republic so like
the droid army was basically
decommissioned and shut down anybody out
there that could be a threat to the to
the empire was removed right that's
basically what that was it was just a
great concept i love the way it was
handled oh but that was the last time we
were here so of course dead bodies are
still littered here which are great
callbacks to these to these stories but
vader as you guys know when he was
anakin was a prodigious droid builder
right he was amazing built c3po build
r2d2 and so that's literally what he
starts doing here is basically building
himself now this is when ochi shows up
now again i don't necessarily know a
whole lot about this guy's history so i
don't know if he's supposed to exist a
certain way but i like the way he exists
here because i'm not gonna lie he kind
of reminds me of a less comical deadpool
and i love it
right like he shows up here and he's
like i know i'm late uh i hope you don't
feel patronized i just really didn't
want this to end all too quickly right
the emperor said that he'd forbidden you
to use the force and when i saw you
dragging yourself with just one arm
across the sand well i respected the
tenacity so i figured i would let you
take this time to kind of put yourself
back together uh get back on your own
two feet as it were and i hope you make
good use of your time because you're
fresh out of it home slice
i love the way he's done here right and
that's kind of the funny thing is he
becomes somewhat of a comedic character
which i feel like is a great dichotomy
in relation to like darth vader now of
course a fight breaks out between the
two and it's largely vader taunting ochi
as much as it is uh ochi kind of
taunting vader but the way that it's
written it's a little ambiguous like
could this guy kind of get the upper
hand on darth vader he doesn't right he
he literally doesn't uh and in the end
it's one of those things where he starts
to interrogate this guy and is like like
what is the emperor planning right
you've been around him what's this guy
planning like what did what is it that
he wants and as this goes on suddenly
ochi starts dropping these small little
things he's like you can't beat him he
has power like more power than you could
possibly imagine and i'm not talking
about using the force i'm not talking
about forced lightning or anything like
that right like power that's way even
beyond your understanding right power
that only the emperor could build and so
that's when vader's like wait a minute
build well one doesn't build the force
right so obviously there's something
else like where is he building this
power that you're talking about and
initially that's when vader's like a
little sketchy about it now of course
the fight that the two of them have ends
up leading them to a kind of cave and
there's a sort of disembodied voice that
vader hears as the two of them are are
basically fighting one another of course
by this point oh she's basically gotten
his hands on vader's lightsaber which is
kind of cool like literally vader throws
it and oh she just grabs it which is
just a really cool moment like i just i
would love to see that in film form it
just looked awesome uh but of course you
know this basically leads to vader kind
of being collapsed by the rubble or at
least being covered by the rebel only to
survive on the other side uh and then in
turn starts making his way to what's
called the eye of webbish bog now as i
understand this the eye of webbish bog
was created for or created by jj abrams
and those guys for the movies but it was
never used it was a deleted scene and so
in essence the explanation of what that
deleted scene is and like why it exists
the backstory behind that is actually
created here uh which is a really cool
thing because as far as i'm aware the
eye of webishbog never existed in the
expanded universe so it's just kind of
uh disney and those guys creating things
for the star wars universe as new
creations that just never existed before
but the cool thing is that as this
conflict and as this fight kind of goes
on of course the emperor's listening is
using the force to monitor everything
that's happening right to keep an eye on
vader and so on and so forth but vader's
kind of reliving these own personal
experiences the conflicts he's had
before things along those lines right
when he killed uh when he when he killed
obi-wan kenobi and like luke skywalker
looked on and really kind of being
haunted by his own memories but the
other part of this is where he's kind of
asking questions like who is this like
you know what's what's happening here
like where he says like like i know
you're force sensitive in some capacity
right i can feel your pull when vader's
like who are you the response he gets is
like who are you right do you even know
have you decided who you are right has
or has your choice been made for you or
have you chosen right like is the
emperor determining your fate or are you
determining your fate yourself if you
could choose would you have been the
chosen one right would you have been the
one who was supposed to bring balance to
the force or would you choose to make
your own choices and you would either
decide to leave the force or to to to
move closer to the force to step into
that role and that's when vader like he
gets a lot of these these cryptic things
and because it's being being spoken
about in such a cryptic way his initial
idea is you're basically like you're you
work for for the emperor right and
that's when the response of the of
webiswag is like no like i do not work
directly for your emperor like i am kind
of basically doing my own thing right i
don't really i don't really have a role
in that but in the end there's just
there's not really any answers given
it's really just a series of questions
here the webish blog even says that you
came here for answers i gave you only
questions i leave you with one more and
he presents him with a wayfinder and
says do you think you passed this test
or failed it and again that's kind of
the cool thing is it's very very
mysterious but the big takeaway is
getting this wayfinder basically leads
him to where it is that the emperor is
building you know using all this power
and all that kind of stuff another fight
breaks out between vader and ochi along
with basically this kind of droid
assassin group um not the most important
thing ever right vader overcomes these
guys and basically uses some of their
components to to enhance his body
rebuild himself a little bit right so
he's not walking around and what are
basically walmart robot parts in effect
right but uh but nonetheless right i
mean these are all dated things this is
stuff from like 20 years ago these the
the components that he's using at the
moment by using these more modern droids
he kind of upgrades himself a little bit
uh but again you know taking these guys
out not the most important thing at that
point he basically snatches up ocean is
like you're coming with me right and
literally throws him in like this pod
and then encloses a man and just like
like connects the way finder to the
navigation of his vessel and then takes
off now the funny thing is like at that
point ochi starts freaking out because
they're literally going to like a
hyperdrive dock and he's like this pod
was not designed for that vader this
thing could like fall apart it could
disintegrate any number of things could
happen when you're traveling and faster
than light speed this was not this was
this is not okay and like vader's just
like i don't care and they just take off
so literally oh she's just screaming for
his life afraid that at any moment the
pod is just gonna break apart in
hyperspace and he'll be scattered across
the stars so
it's a pretty horrifying concept but the
other cool thing that's going on here is
that one of emperor palpatine's most
significant aids is here which is a
woman by the name of sly moore who's
also an ambara now even if you don't
know her name you've seen her before if
you remember in episodes one two and
three where you basically had that bald
chick who had those crazy looking eyes
who basically hung out alongside emperor
palpatine or really when he was just
chancellor palpatine before people knew
he was a sith lord that's her so it's
cool to see that like she continues on
now she had a very instrumental role in
helping him rise to power because she is
a force sensitive a force adept and she
has the ability to control the minds of
others so she's not necessarily on the
same level of power as somebody like
palpatine or i would even say she's not
on the same level as vader but she's
still highly capable and is really one
of his closest confidants and so that's
one of the things is because where ochi
basically is viewed to have failed she's
the one now with the task of taking out
vader so it's a cool little thing to see
i love that right i think it's a cool
concept now of course at that point they
literally just start firing off like her
and these these two other star
destroyers just start firing off like
all these different tie fighters and of
course as you would expect vader just
starts eliminating them right with just
seemingly the greatest of ease because
let's be honest with ourselves vader's
probably the best pilot in the galaxy at
this point in time right he's just
ridiculously capable but of course
there's also just this gigantic monster
that exists out there now the way it's
explained by sly moore is that these are
at least this is a subspecies of what's
called the summa vermin off uh which i'm
not a hundred percent sure if we've seen
those frequently maybe we have somebody
else could could specify if that was the
case or not but the the super verona
those things are massive right they're
like four and a half miles long like
they're just huge right they're largely
born in space they just consume
seemingly everything that comes within
their path this particular subspecies
were i think this is like the only time
we ever see this uh but basically the
way this thing exists is to literally
hunt its own kind and so in order to
achieve that the way it's explained by
sly moore is that it basically started
developing the ability to launch psychic
attacks and in doing that it could
likely just shock the mind of its own
kind and then consume and destroy them
but this one just kind of exists out
there as what's really more of a
protector for what emperor palpatine has
likely is being manipulated through the
force or something along those lines but
when vader and his guys or really vader
and ochi take off because of just the
sheer number of tie fighters that they
can't overcome uh they end up flying
directly into the path of this thing
which of course immediately starts you
know attacking the tie fighters and
destroying them but launches a psychic
attack against darth vader now the cool
thing here and and really the way this
is done it's phenomenal because when
vader is confronted with this psychic
attack he has these own visions right
these kind of memory recollections where
he recalls you know standing over luke
skywalker where he says like the force
is with you young skywalker but you are
not a jedi yet right like probably one
of darth vader's most iconic lines from
the insta and entire star wars franchise
uh you know of course the moment when
you have obi-wan kenobi standing over
vader different things on those lines
back when he's anakin cutting off the
hand of luke but one of the cool things
is that because of the nature of this
psychic attack that it kind of seems to
go back and forth now what is up going
on here is luke skywalker as you guys
know from return of the jedi cuts off
the hand of darth vader and confronts
him and that that in the end where where
darth vader besieges luke skywalker and
is like no right please do not do this
you can destroy the emperor he has
foreseen this it's your destiny join me
and together as father and son we can
rule the galaxy that luke skywalker
kills darth vader and that when that
happens he full-on becomes the the new
apprentice of basically emperor
palpatine and so that seems to be the
driving force especially going forward
behind why it is that darth vader works
so hard to keep luke skywalker from
falling into the service of emperor
palpatine now again a lot of what goes
on with that is really him saying like
we can rule everything right the rule of
two when it comes to the sith one master
one apprentice together you and i can
kill the emperor and then in turn we can
rule together i will be the master you
will be the apprentice and we'll rule
the galaxy together so it's not as one
of those things where he's like we can
kill the emperor luke and then free the
galaxy that's not really what he says
you guys know that right just from the
the various histories that are there but
once they pass through that whole
situation and they arrive on this planet
called exigal which you guys know from
basically rise of skywalker that it's a
cool thing there right that when they
get there it's like okay we both
experienced this vision ochi never
really talks about what happened of
course seemingly we already know just
from you know rise of skywalker and so
on and so forth but uh when this again
this giant monster shows up that vader
actually does what he's not supposed to
do and he taps into the force and uses
it to ensnare this thing and when that
happens he literally uses it as a mode
of transportation and rides over to
where the emperor is at and then demands
the emperor show himself now this is one
of the things that i really loved about
palpatine like palpatine this guy is
basically fearless and a lot of it just
seems to be how powerful he is but i
would say more so than that it's rooted
in how well he knows darth vader but if
this was just like a random person who
was really powerful in the force and
just showed up here and maybe they had
killed darth vader and now they're
confronting emperor palpatine right just
some op jedi that escaped his view by
one reason or another you might see a
little shudder of fear uh but here this
dude's just fearless right he's just
like literally like like vader is just
like i am not your apprentice anymore
and palpatine's like i mean okay sure
yeah i guess and then just like destroys
the thing like the giant beast and vader
just comes crashing down to the earth
and he's like you were saying right like
i mean come on dude i'm emperor
palpatine's son
it's gonna take more than a tentacle
monster to scare me and so the funny
thing is what vader's wanted to know all
this time is what is palpatine working
on and because we know that palpatine
effectively has the upper hand between
the two of them and because of the fact
that he that really vader's curiosity is
running high more than anything else
he's like come with me right i know you
sense a kind of pain that exists inside
this place but come with me and what we
get to a degree is kind of what we
already saw in rise of skywalker right
like the giant statues and you know the
the tanks that contain these beings that
uh palpatine was basically trying to
create ultimately palpatine creating
clones of himself essentially the hand
of luke skywalker's just hovering there
which is kind of weird but one of the
other things that palpatine has been
working on is basically a series of
beings that are wildly powerful in the
dark side of the force and essentially
could challenge or really could replace
darth vader should he fall they're not
really sith but
in the end they would basically serve
the same purpose right like that's what
palpatine says like like they could be
should you fall and the response of
vader is like i will not fall and
literally goes through and just clears
all these guys out right just like like
kills all these guys at that point you
have like you know the dark side
cultists who come running out and vader
uses the force to snatch all their
daggers out of their hands and then kill
them with them all i mean the guy
literally demonstrates himself to just
be a one-man army here that just shows
up and just starts crushing everybody
now a lot of that's also because
palpatine's not stopping him right if
anything like darth vader is just using
violence to achieve his ends and as you
guys know using violence in relation to
the force that's how you fall to the
dark side or maintain a connection to
the dark side and so ultimately what
vader's really demonstrating here to
palpatine if nothing else is that he's
not gone back to the light side and so
that's why palpatine's just kind of like
okay we'll sort of let these things go
on but this is when palpatine reveals to
vader what we discovered in riza
skywalker that he's building all these
new uh these new star destroyers right a
thousand times more powerful than the
galaxy's ever seen before each one with
a canon powerful enough to destroy a
world right so literally just eliminate
any and all opposition but the big
question that was being asked here that
vader was really curious about is how is
all this being powered right how is all
this being done and that's when
essentially palpatine keeps moving
forward and vader and ochi basically end
up traveling into this source of power
which turns out to be a giant kyber
crystal now for those of you guys who
don't know kyber crystals are living
organisms right they're like a living
mineral uh and that in the end whenever
it comes to a person training whether
they're a sith or they are a jedi hybrid
crystals are used with their lightsabers
now initially it was just a kyber
crystal powers lightsaber and that was
it the expanded universe in star wars
actually adjusted that so depending on
what kind of kyber crystal you have you
can actually have different properties
with a lightsaber so darth vader's
lightsaber using his kyber crystals is
different from the lightsaber of luke
skywalker using his uh his kyber
crystals and that was a way to explain
in the star wars mythos how it is that
one lightsaber is quote unquote stronger
than another that kind of a thing why
lightsabers have different properties
different effects the lightsaber can
have so again it's a cool thing but in
effect because the kyber crystal is a
living organism each time a piece of it
is cut it quite literally cries out in
the force now the thing about this is
that when this lightsaber crystal's cut
and it sends off this massive shock of
energy what it does is it blows off the
helmet of ochi and then incinerates his
eyes and that's why he ends up having
those crazy little eye devices that you
basically saw him with in future
depictions but quite literally there's a
point where vader tries to tap into the
power of the kyber crystal and use it
and in the end like the emperor realizes
what it is what it is he's trying to do
and he's like that's ridiculous right
this is the kind of power that i have
vader like the like the power of a kyber
crystal unlimited power here you cannot
stop me there's no conceivable way for
you to destroy me so this pain that you
feel this emotional mental physical pain
that you experience if you walk with me
and keep this power you will forever
know this pain right so long as you live
you will experience this pain over and
over and over again but you will have
this level of power you will you will be
able to utilize this kind of power i
will let you the
the unspoken agreement here is not
enough to destroy me but enough to have
a level of power that you've never had
before or you can turn against me and
you can be destroyed and so of course if
for no other reason than
self-preservation but really more due to
the fact that it's just a huge amount of
power that's available to him that in
the end darth vader sides with with
emperor palpatine but one of the cool
things about this and this is where i
would really argue vader is still on the
path to joining the light side is this
presents a level of power that vader can
use to kill the emperor because as you
guys know even when it comes to the rule
of two and the sith the goal of the
apprentice is at all times to kill his
master or her master and then ascend to
the role of master and take their own
apprentice that's like the governing
principles of the sith it's the natural
order of things right it's just it's
literally what palpatine leans into
that's why he allows vader to do the
kind of things that he does why he
doesn't really stand against vader
whenever whenever vader gets like hyper
violent or anything like that because if
vader demonstrates his power is growing
or he demonstrates he's becoming more
capable and he basically becomes
powerful enough to strike down emperor
palpatine i mean while palpatine won't
just stand by and let it happen if
vader's powerful enough to destroy
palpatine then it means he is more
powerful and he is the rightful ruler of
the sith and the empire so it's a cool
thing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section about this about the
darth vader comics because it's just
it's crazy and uh yeah i will catch you
all later
peace
you